could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
i grew from nothing to 12 000 employees
2.4 billion turnover john caldwell the
billionaire founder of phones for you as
it relates to his wealth
he has it all but it's come
at a real cost i was sitting on the edge
of my seat nearly every day for 20 years
facing threat after threat after threat
after threat it did nearly finish me i
think anybody's would you know because
you can't work 22 hours a day under
immense pressure it's a monster deal the
biggest ever been done in the
marketplace by anybody you know i don't
mind fair competition but it was very
unethical
if i didn't find a solution it was
instantly terminal you know my turnover
was going to drop immediately my stores
were empty
nothing i'd have been bankrupt and i
wouldn't be here talking to you today
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the diver ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
i suppose if i'd had a little bit more
love i would have been happier
do you remember saying that
i don't actually but i can understand
why i might have said it why do you
think you might have said that um
it's yeah it would certainly be to do
with my childhood
um because my
father was uh
not the kindest to me uh not abusive but
not in a way well in a way maybe he was
abusive but not abusive in the way
normal sense of it he just wasn't very
fair with me and certainly not very
affectionate and i think my mother was
struggling through all those early
childhood years
so i understand completely why i might
say
if i'd had a bit more love i might have
been happier uh so it's quite a true
point
when you say your father wasn't so kind
to you
was that because he was
he was suffering with something or he
was
did you ever diagnose why he wasn't kind
to you not at the time but in more
recent years probably came to understand
it i think um
i think certainly one of the points was
that i was quite a rebellious child uh
we were brought up
in the back streets of stoke-on-trent in
the terraced houses and uh
you know it was football in the streets
and your mother coming down the road
shouting for you and i'd go hiding and
all my mates would say when when she
asked where i was oh we don't know we
haven't seen him and i'd behind me
behind somebody's front courtyard wall
so i was a nuisance and uh
you know i was difficult uh as a child
and uh very adventurous wanted
excitement all the time and that for
parents is very very difficult so i
think that was probably one of the
things but i think also he'd been
brought up with
certain
strange values really that didn't really
work very well he hadn't made a
transition to yet a different generation
so he put me on an old army and navy
shoes
from the army and navy store
uh which crippled me and so i was out in
the streets you know playing football
and so on and expected to keep these
shoes perfectly like you might be in the
army and when i came back with them
scuffed i was in serious trouble and i
couldn't stop them from being scuffed at
the same time my feet were crippled it
just got some strange values i mean i
suppose in today's age you would say
that was child abuse but um
um
it was just the way he was and and i
think when i've spoken to some of his
friends
um over the last 30 40 years
they think that he came back with ptsd
from the war and of course it was never
diagnosed in those days um
and he he came back and he got a lot of
wonderful qualities he would never see
anybody in trouble he was almost the
first day without it being paid for
because he was an engineer very capable
very ingenious and any car broken down
on the roadside where people were in
trouble he'd just stop and help them out
i'd be quite grateful for that on one
one count uh
uh i'd have to wait in the car for an
hour while he fixed the car but i knew
a you know a couple of shillings or half
a crown was going to come my way as a
result
so you know it was a sort of this this
childhood of uh where i'd got a lot of
respect for my father in some ways but
in other ways the way he treated me was
very unfair
and uh and
not in a kind way on many occasions
and um
i realized that you you lost your mother
recently so i wanted to first say i'm
sorry for your loss and i know that um
it can't be easy coming and doing this
so soon after so i also want to thank
you for you know coming and doing this
because i know that
well i can't imagine you know the
difficulty of all of that um
i when i was doing the research on your
story i was reading about your
relationship with her and your father
um
and and that dynamic and there was a lot
of
things within your relationship that
really resonated with me um so i wanted
to ask about that relationship and those
dynamics because i know that's really
really really formative in your story
as well so what was the relationship
like with your mother and your father
and you as a three
um well in the early days we lived with
my grandmother my grandmother didn't
like my mother
um i think she was a very jealous person
she adored me so my relationship with my
grandmother was amazing
she you know she would do anything for
me but at the same time she treated my
mother very very badly
um and there was lots of rows in the
household so it was not a happy place to
be really it was
a place full of um for me fears and
almost at time no terrors is too strong
a word but certainly fears
and insecurities because i never really
knew whether my mother and father were
going to survive the experience
so it was it was very very tough days
and very formative days
um but
you know and you can look back and say i
wish you'd been different
and you and your listeners might expect
that i would say that but i absolutely
don't i would never have changed it
because it taught me a lot
and failure or difficulties teach you a
lot more than success because if you're
analytical and you look at what went
wrong or what the situation was
you can learn so much from it
and what i learned from my father
was that
i would never ever be unfair
to another human being if i could
possibly avoid it especially to my
children and i also learned to make sure
that all the people in my life that mata
felt extremely loved by me
and i told them that on a daily basis
because they can come a point when it's
too late
when you come to understand
in hindsight why your father might have
been the way he was
um or when i sit here with their guests
and they kind of they talk about their
parents a lot of the time you see these
kind of generational cycles where their
parents treated them in a certain way so
they kind of inherited those values or
that way of behaving and then they've
kind of they've treated
their children in the same way
i
sometimes worry especially as i've got a
little bit older
i see certain patterns in my behavior
that i
didn't love from my parents
um
small things it might be my temper
sometimes or it might be you know other
other things do you ever when you've
gone through an experience like that in
a home where there it was a little bit
heated and you as you said your father
had a little bit of a temper do you ever
worry or catch glimpses of um
your childhood reoccurring today and
think i need to not
i need to not pass that on i need to not
repeat that cycle
it's a very good question um
i'm a long long way off perfect so i do
recognize characteristics of myself very
regularly that i don't admire
but
i've learned a huge amount from my
parents mistakes and
in many respects um
gone to do the opposite
and
by and large i do achieve the opposite
i do have my father's temper
i do have characteristics of my father
but
by and large i'm very comfortable with
who i am because
i do a huge amount of positive things in
life for everybody in my life and
it's it's actually the biggest sense of
satisfaction to me so yes i make lots of
mistakes
i made one yesterday you know i was
irritated with my partner because she
interrupted a meeting and then got a bit
off with me because i couldn't take the
call
and i got angry with her you know and
then i rang up later and said that you
were wrong to take that attitude with me
but
uh but uh you know let's just forget it
now
yeah we all we all
make mistakes i think i think if you've
got
spirit and character and drive and
passion you're always going to be uh
full of human failings and the the trick
is to minimize those human failings and
to maximize
what a human being should be
with acts of kindness and
and uh looking after people and and i
what i taught my children was there was
two things that were very very important
in their lives or important to me for
what they became
and it wasn't success not in the normal
measures of success it was just two
things be happy
and leave the world a better place than
you found it
and if you can do that i as a father i'm
going to be just the happiest man alive
and and your happiness might mean that
you have to be successful it might mean
they have to be a hugely successful
business person or whatever but that
doesn't matter to me what matters is
that you're happy and leave the world a
better place
as you've gone on that um journey of
like self-awareness and understanding
who you are and striving to be better in
various areas um was there something
that helped your journey to
self-awareness um
more than more than anything else what
was it was it feedback from others is it
journaling what allowed you to kind of
look yourself
in the mirror or from a bird's-eye view
and say
this is not good and i want to improve
on that thing
do you know i think there's been no
epiphany i think the epiphany was when i
was young learning that lesson about
fairness that fairness is crucial and
and i think it's the number one quality
people need i mean there's lots of other
important ones ones like loyalty and
faithfulness and so on and so forth
and morality there's a huge amount of
important qualities but i think it
starts with fairness
and that that that was
sort of traumatically imposed upon my
psyche as a youngster after that it was
all developmental recognizing the
mistakes i was making one after another
feedback from and understanding those
mistakes understanding that what i'd
done might have been hurtful or damaging
to another human being realizing that i
didn't want to be that person that
caused difficulty
um
you know and running the business it was
a very very very tough environment i
grew from nothing to
12 000 employees from zero
to uh 2.4 billion turnover
and uh
and i was a hard taskmaster and i've
never regretted that but at times
my hardness turned into unfairness and
that i was upset by
and i'd usually recognize it afterwards
maybe not always maybe there's a people
out there that say oh no you were you're
a terrible boss a lot of people say i
was a great boss but i'm sure there's
going to be people out there that were
um
damaged in some way by me being too
harsh
and possibly unfair at times but it was
always something i was striving to avoid
but i am only human you know
we all as humans make mistakes
especially when you're growing an empire
at the speed that i was growing it in
one of the toughest and most aggressive
environments there's ever been
so do because i can i can relate to that
sometimes i feel like i'm a little bit
hard and it's usually after the fact
when i
leave the situation or spend some time
alone or i go to the gym at night and i
think you know i i think i should handle
that situation with with maybe a little
bit more empathy
or my reaction probably didn't get the
best out of the people in that situation
was it those reflective moments on your
own where you look back on it or was it
years later
you know i think almost immediately
afterwards really if if i was angry
about something um
i've always been one to level out very
quickly no matter how angry and
frustrated i am
five minutes later i can be calm
and reflective
and maybe regret my actions
so i'm very very quick to be
self-admonishing
and
and then sometimes i'd say well i think
to myself well
you know i didn't behave correctly there
but the end result's still the right
result so i can't really do anything to
put it right because it just has to be
that way
but i'd still be self-critical i mean
you know i think i think criticism
especially self-criticism is one of the
most powerful things in life you know
every aspect of my business
i was criticizing all the time
looking for better ways of doing it
looking for how we could be bigger
better higher quality how we could
capture more market share
and for that you've got to be different
you've got to do things differently i
very much believe that don't do anything
the way anybody else does it you know
always
be contentious not necessarily
contentious in the way you
approach people but contentious in the
way you approach situations
and systems or methodologies
so i i
one of my absolute edicts in life was
try and do something very different to
everybody else now
we've all seen the chief executives
who've come into a business and they
need to do something different than the
predecessor and they make change for
changes sake and that's destructive
so when i say something do something
different it has to be different but so
intelligently different that what you do
is make a quantum leap forward
so one of my rules for every employee i
used to say
never never change it's the destruction
of business
but i'd immediately follow on by saying
but if you don't change
you will fail
now that's a mixed message i know but
then i would explain it and say look if
the change is going to make a massive
quantum leap forward
make the change if you're uncertain
about it
it's not worth the risk because the
change will be detrimental because
you've got to retrain all of those
people and what's the point of making
small changes for the sake of them don't
do it because you think you've got to
achieve something do it because it's
going to make a big difference to the
business model
and i could get that message through to
some people but it is a difficult one to
understand and and of course also
judgment comes into it because you've
got a impeccable judgment to try and see
through what the end result might be
um to
whatever you're trying to change
and that drive that you're talking about
to be bigger and to be better and to
change as you reflect um because in the
moment
i am i'm imagining that especially when
you're younger in business and i mean
you started you know the car dealership
and you were selling toys and books the
drive you had at that moment
i i imagine it's almost a little bit
subconscious you just wake up in the
morning and you just want to change your
life and you just feel driven but as you
reflect on your life and that drive and
hunger you had
does it feel to you like it was probably
in fact insecurity
life's complicated isn't it when you
analyze yourself it's a complicated mix
of lots of component parts but i think
first of all i was born to be an
entrepreneur
stroke salesman i was born to be that
there is no doubt about that whatsoever
and and these early attributes showed
themselves when i was four or five
but i do think uh to your point of
insecurity
the
having that insecurity does drive you
on a lot further you know i hate failure
and love success
and do is that born out of insecurity
well i think to a point but it's also
borne out of pride you know it's the
pride of wanting to succeed the pride of
wanting to change things for the better
whether it's my charitable
interests or whether it's business i
feel the same about everything in life
in fact
people find me very difficult to live
with because my attention to detail is
immense
and i pick up on the tiniest things one
of my one of my directors once said to
me in in frustration i might add it
wasn't complimentary
he uh because i'd picked up on something
he said you know he said i could build
you the best house in the world
and one of the tiles might be missing on
off the roof and that's all you'd focus
on
and we can all focus on our successes
but it's not our successes that make us
successful it's their failures and what
we get wrong and putting them right but
that's sometimes very difficult for the
recipient to live with it's not
difficult for me to live with for my
failures because i take it on the chin
and i put it right and move on
but for the recipients that might be
being criticized at the time as much as
i might do it try and do it in a
constructive way it's still a criticism
and uh and i think that can be very
difficult for people when i pick up on
every last detail where they've not
actually got it quite right i was just
saying to my manager yesterday i i was
saying i think
the balance that i need to be better at
striking is i spend too much time
focused on
possible improvements and not at enough
time celebrating
current progress
so i'm always trying to find you know
how we can be better and dwelling on
that as opposed to dwelling on the
progress that's been made and sometimes
i think for some people that can make it
feel like you're not giving them enough
recognition or you're not praising as
much as you're criticizing right
have you found that there needs to be a
healthy balance between the two or is
that okay i've always been criticized
for not praising people enough right
always being criticized for that
um but
what i know in life
is that if you're in a very very
aggressive competitive environment
where you need every last ounce out of a
person
you do need to give them incentives and
motivation and they do need to feel good
about themselves to an extent
but if they feel too good about
themselves
then their ego goes up and ego is always
a source of destruction ego is never a
good thing and it's this balance between
making them feel valued
but not letting their ego get out of
check
and this was a huge problem for me in
the mobile phone world because
because we were the leaders in the uk
and i was reputed to be a hard task
master and drive people to achieve the
very best
all of my people were poached
by the competitors they all wanted them
you know so i had this really difficult
balance to drive between not giving them
too much feeling of self-worth because
that would make them more likely to
accept a job somewhere else i mean this
sounds a bit negative but it was reality
it would give them too much for feeling
self-worth and make them too likely to
jump ship but then the contra to that
was making them feel part of an enormous
winning organization that they could
never get that satisfaction anywhere
else and putting wealth creation schemes
in that rewarded them for long-term
loyalty and long-term performance
and i did lots and lots of innovative
schemes like that to make people feel
valued i'd run competitions i'd do all
sorts of things but one of the smartest
things i probably did
i've never told anybody this before
really i mean my employees know it so
they come to me like every managing
director does with the budget and this
is the business plan for next year and
what do they always do they always try
and sell you on the lowest achievement
possible because a that makes them look
a success when they bust when they bust
the
numbers and b they get the full bonus
so
one of my classic styles would be to say
i was not really ambitious enough for me
i said but
if
that's all you think you can achieve
and you're lacking the ambition to do
any better
then fine i'll accept it but you
certainly won't be getting a pay rise on
your basic
now these guys might be on 250k basic
and 250k bonus say so the bonus was
really important to them but so was the
basic
you know and so i played
basic
versus bonus
and versus ambition
so they knew if they came back came in
and tried to blag me with low numbers so
they got the full bonus they wouldn't
get a basic pay rise so the basic pay
rise was linked to their uh to their
ambition
but it's a really difficult thing in
a market as volatile as the mobile phone
business was because it was colossally
colossally volatile and it was really
difficult if you if you made five
million pounds this year on one
particular business it was very
difficult to say with that we can
achieve this growth and we can get to
six million next year because there'd be
things coming at you from left base that
could decimate your business
one of my businesses and mobile phone
distribution i had 20 businesses within
mobile phones
the distribution business which we were
selling handsets all throughout the uk
and just the handsets
motorola dropped the price on me
overnight
having delivered a huge amount of stock
into my warehouse and dropped the price
overnight in the marketplace by 50
pounds
it wrote off 15 million pounds off my p
l
when i'd only expected to make six
so there was all of those issues all the
time i mean it was really a fight to the
bitter end here to grow my business so
it was a very very tough environment
i really want to go on to the to that
which is how tough it was scaling that
business to you know
the tremendous valuation it reached and
the exit you had um i was just thinking
then as you were speaking
um you know you were talking then about
kind of your your ability to understand
people and get the best out of them
which was so evident there
and it made me ask myself the question
in my head like what were the skills you
had in business that you were really
good at and the skills you had in
business where you weren't good at like
i can look at myself and say okay i'm
like you very uniquely good at this
stuff but i know i'm terrible at x y and
z and i ask that question in part
because entrepreneurs sometimes fall
into the trap of believing that they
need to be good at everything to succeed
but when you look at the greats like sir
you know richard branson
and so on
i'm not actually good at that many
things according to a lot of people but
very very good at what he was good at so
what was your sort of um well i think
first of all
one of my unique points was opposite of
what you just said it was that i was
good at everything but not great at
everything right so i was good at
everything i was usually the best at any
one of the areas of my employees
and what my goal was always was to have
somebody in a discipline that was not
better than me that i could admire it
was difficult to find but of course i
did find those people i had to do
because i wasn't good enough at all of
those disciplines to grow the business
to where i did so i had to find those
people but initially the
the the reason for success was that i
was good at everything
but everything but i wasn't great at
everything now if you then look at when
i then later on as the business group
identified my weaknesses and strengths
my commercial intellect was the real
the real
massive attribute
along with resilience if you look at my
six critical success fit factors
ambition drive resilience passion
commercial intellect and leadership
of all of those
um commercial intellect was probably the
number one quality but with
huge resilience
and uh and it's that resilience that
enabled me to fight when everything was
collapsing around me and to still fight
through the depths of despair and just
keep going and my health mental health
and physical health to hold up and to
keep going
so it was definitely though those two if
you look at my weaknesses i managed to
plug those because whilst i was a great
innovator and i'd say right that's what
we're going to do now go away and do it
i was dreadful at following up and i
would never
follow up properly but i plugged that by
by having somebody that was really in to
the follow-up detail so he would hold
the people to account he was my
right-hand man
he would hold the people to account
where i'd set the task and the challenge
and maybe innovated a whole new way of
doing something he would then follow up
and make sure that they did
i was very poor at that for whatever
reason i don't know i think i was just
on to the next brainwave you know and on
to the next creation
whilst i've got an amazing attention to
detail spontaneous detail i'm not very
good at just going back week in week out
to
look at something and check it's being
done properly so i did need somebody to
do that for me
quick one for many years people have
been asking for a coffee flavoured heel
and quite recently he'll release the
iced coffee caramel flavor of their
ready to drink heels and i've just
become hooked on it over the last couple
of weeks i've been on a really
interesting journey with huel which i've
described and talked about a little bit
on this podcast i started with the berry
ready to drink then i moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now i'm balanced between
them both i drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink i've got really
into the iced coffee caramel flavor of
heels ready to drink and now i'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as i said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
smash hit so check it out let me know
what you think on social media i see all
of your tags and instagram posts and
tweets about you back to the podcast
one of the things you described earlier
is um one of your sort of strength
factors or success factors was this this
word resilience
now as you look at your life
before we go into the the key moments
where it was important for you to be
resilient and all of the turmoil you
went through across your business career
where did that resilience come from in
you and where do you think it comes from
in people generally because i know
there's an argument to say you know i
was born with it but for me when i look
at your story i think you know
it was like you know you went through a
bit of a tumultuous um childhood and
there was a lot of stress put on you
which you learned how to deal with which
you know
having sat here with a lot of people and
people that had a certain resilience to
them it tends to be the case that
they've been through quite a tough
moulding to build that is that accurate
um well i absolutely think i was born
with it it's a characteristic that
you're born with um
you're born with a
you can see all around the world you're
born with a degree of physical
resilience and mental resilience and no
matter how much you train somebody
you're not going to put the level of
resilience in that somebody might need
whether the
upbringing adds to that resilience or
detract so i wouldn't really know and
some people it will detract there's an
old expression isn't there what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger clearly it's
not true you know but in some cases it
is now in my case i would say i was born
with that resilience and that's a real
look of birth you know if you've got
these characteristics that are positive
that that's just pure luck of birth
but then you can do with them what you
wish and of course the external
environment or in this case my
upbringing probably added to that
resilience and uh strengthened me even
more but another person it might have
weakened and left them scarred so it's a
it's a tricky one really but um
but
i i would never
want to see anybody have
the challenges that i had and hope that
they would survive because they might
not
you know and
i wouldn't want to gamble
that that would make them stronger
because it might not make them stronger
and in a lot of cases i know it wouldn't
you know i've seen it amongst my 12 000
employees i always remember the day when
one of my guys who was under
immense pressure
um rang me up from the car sobbing
it was about seven o'clock in the
morning said i can't come in today
um and i won't mention his name because
he might be embarrassed by it but i said
what
where what's happened where are you he
said
i don't know he said i'm in the car
halfway to work and i just can't
can't move can't drive can't do anything
i just can't come in
and i instantly thought god you know
something very serious is going wrong
here so i said i said to look just sit
in the car where are you just send me a
send me give me your address and i'll
come to you and i went to him and it was
clear that he was having a bit of a
nervous breakdown
now
that didn't make him stronger
well fortunately i gave him about two or
three months off work and he did recover
and when he came back to work i took a
load of responsibilities off him put
those into other areas and let him have
an easy entry back into his role and he
did become a very valuable employee
again
and uh it was one of my success stories
under multiple level uh a success story
you've rescued somebody
but um
but
those sorts of pressures i was under
every day and i never cracked now why
was it because of my upbringing you know
was i just gifted at birth
and i think it's this birthright that
you know you just so lucky if you're
born with those qualities
and then you can try and make them the
best that you can do after that
i i resonate with what you've said there
in terms of i i
and i think the science is also supports
the idea that many people are
predisposed with a certain level of
resilience and the way they process
information is a little bit more
um
protects them a little bit more from the
external world um
i think one of the flaws in that when
you're one of those people tends to be
that it becomes harder to empathize with
those that are um suffering and i've i
struggled with that because because i do
feel like you know i went through fairly
stressful my company went public and i
grew up from my bedroom when i was 20
years old um and i struggled for a while
with understanding why people didn't
think the way that i thought and
couldn't deal with the things that i
could deal with
and that was a and i came to maybe an
understanding at 23 that was a real risk
if i couldn't emphasize with the fact
that people's brains weren't the same as
mine and they didn't have the same level
of driving you know do you relate to
that oh absolutely i'm still struggling
with it now yeah
i'm pragmatic about it because you know
the way i look at that
and i did learn that in my 30s i guess
but
didn't really ever accept it i couldn't
understand why somebody bright who had
been to oxbridge didn't get it
and there's me you know giving up
a-levels abandoned you know and
not caught considering myself to be an
intellectual at all could see it crystal
clear and why couldn't this person see
it and you're right it does cause a lot
lack of empathy a lack of thrust
and increases frustration
but pragmatically
it it had to be that way because if
everybody could see it the way i'd see
it i'd just be one of the crowd i would
never have had the success that i had so
the qualities that i was born with and
that helped me to succeed if everybody
was the same well i'd just be one of
seven billion people on the same path
you know so you then look at it in a
different way that uh you just feel very
lucky that you've got those qualities
and rather than criticizing other people
that haven't got them
try and look at it that you're very
lucky to have them
and to look after those people and get
the best out of them that you can in
their particular area and try and limit
the i guess trying to limit the
downsides of having those qualities
because for me like the obsessiveness
the drive the lack of empathy for why
people couldn't see the world and this
didn't see the world the same way i saw
it not saying that i saw it in a better
way because as i say there's lots of
costs to seeing the world in a certain
in any way no matter how you see the
world as a cost
whether that's you become
incredibly lonely
or you you know abandon romantic
relationships whatever um on that point
of resilience then
can you take me to the first time in
your business professional career where
you genuinely
the first hard moment the first moment
where you thought this is it
gosh i mean i've had thousands but
and they were all a different level of
crisis
i'll deal with the first that
that really worried me um
i i i was a
michelin tyre company engineer was a
foreman um
in the
tie making department on the engineering
side
and uh during that time i started
selling cars and i sold them to all my
michelin people
um but i was trading from home
and the neighbors complained because
they saw all these cars coming and going
i kept it as discreet as i could of
course but they saw them and they
complained and the planners came down
and
told me i'd got to to cease
so suddenly i panicked because this is
this was the start of what i saw of my
future to try and create some wealth and
some
success and so
i panicked into this uh car sales site
and opened up this car sales site but i
hadn't really got enough money to stock
it properly so i went to my mother
and i said could we mortgage your house
mom
and that'll allow us to buy
um
another 20 cars i think it was from the
from the mortgage that would uh we'd be
able to get
and uh
don't worry about it because i will
never ever fail you you'll never lose
your house and furthermore when i make
money i'll relocate you to where you
want to be on the side of the mallvan
hills by your lovely house there and so
you'll do well i'll tell you she didn't
even hesitate
which is remarkable really because
you know i've got no real proper success
um history there for her to judge from
um she just did desire to love and uh
did it instantly so coming to the answer
of the question of the trauma
all went well during the summer
but
as november came sales dropped off a
cliff
and we started losing money hand over
fist because there was just no sales it
was a very very grim november
uh and december and all the cars were
frozen up you know it was one of those
winters that were just horrendous back
almost before you were probably was
before you were born actually
so 92. no it was before then it was
about 80
1982 perhaps um
but but they dropped off a cliff
now we weren't in financial difficulty
but
the trajectory
would have put us on it and
i started really really really panicking
and there was not much i could do about
it because every time i went to a car
you couldn't even open the door it was
frozen solid the batteries were always
flat
there was no customers anyway
we couldn't clear the frost off or with
the great difficulty if you hosed it
down with water the water would freeze i
mean it was a nightmare a complete
nightmare and i started having visions
of letting my mother down and failing
her in a bad way
and uh it really drove me uh at the time
i was still working at mitchell entire
company i was doing 50 hours a week
there
i was doing probably
70 or 80 hours a week at the car sales
site as well and going out and doing all
the buying
i remember for a period of six months
i worked 22 hours a day one week and
three because i was on night shift at
michelin that week and on that night
shift i'd get home at 7 00 a.m
i'd have two hours with my well one and
a half two hours with my wife uh enough
i'd be going to the auctions buying cars
during the day running the car sales
site at night until i went to work it's
11 o'clock on the
night shift again and i did that one
week and three for about six months it
didn't nearly finish me i was on
tranquilizers because it was i was
wretching and i was so
uh disturbed you know i was in a real
mess but i was able to function when you
say tranquilizers you mean like
anti-anxiety yes i think there were
if i remember rightly i think they were
librium
just a car a acidity that the doctor had
given me i wasn't feeling anxious
um my nervous system was just shot
i just got so much stress and pressure
to save my mother's house even though it
wasn't under immediate threat but i've
always done that i've always seen the
threat a long way in advance which is
what keeps you safe because then you
react but it didn't keep me safe
physically because you know it put me
under enormous pressure to try and make
certain that day never came have you
seen throughout your career how your
body ends up holding the score there's
the book written about how our body even
if our mind hasn't acknowledged the
threat um hasn't acknowledged the fear
consciously our body will quickly tell
us through
symptoms like the one you've described
there that we are under threat because i
noticed in my business whenever we had
payroll issues or whenever cash got
tight
i would get sick
like i would the only time in the seven
years that i ran the business where i
would get a cold or a flu
was like 48 hours
um around the time that i'd found out
that we had a cash issue
and although i thought i was this like
tough guy that who could just he was
dealing with everything clearly my body
had its own
you know
mind
yeah
i've sort of been quite lucky mostly
because that's the only time i can
remember my body
rebellion but i think anybody's would
you know because you can't work 22 hours
a day under immense pressure you just
cannot do it i get an hour and a half
sleep
you know and doing that for seven nights
seven days you just you just i don't
think anybody could probably do it and
it's probably the only time that my
system started to fail but then with the
odd tranquilizer i was able to keep
going you know so
uh it calm you know calmness whatever
with this wretching was it calmed it
down i was okay and then i had no other
symptoms and this is just pure look of
life you know it's just the look of life
that uh
nothing's been able to cave me in
and uh
you know there was a i was thinking when
i answered that question do i tell you
about my mother well i told you that
because it's very topical for me at the
moment having lost my mother and feeling
very emotional about that but uh but
that was a very emotional occasion to
make certain that i
that i didn't let it out but
uh in the early years of uh cellular
we had probably 90 percent of our
business was through motorola motorola
were world leaders by a long way
and uh
the the other 10 was a bit here and a
bit there the odd panasonic the odd
nokia but really almost inconsequential
because motorola had the entire market
share
and the relationship with motorola was
always very tenuous because although we
we came to sell vast volumes it was a
bit of a
well they they always referred it as the
tail wagging the dog you know when the
tail wags the dog they don't like it so
when they're encouraging you to do huge
volumes for them that's wonderful as you
gain volume you're getting power as you
gain power they feel vulnerable and as
they feel vulnerable they want to cut
your power i mean this was with every
manufacturer with everything in my life
i grew these people and then they wanted
to chop me down because i grew too
powerful and they didn't like that
situation
anyway this uh motorola had been
threatening me for
a couple of years it was very weird
because on the one hand they they would
encourage me to do something then they
might get a plate because i'd exported
to china perfectly legitimately but
exported to china they didn't like that
so then they get a complaint from the
chinese you know the people that were in
those territories
the english guys were very happy because
i'd done the volume
the chinese guys were
complaining to head office the complaint
came back to the uk and the uk
they're not to come and say well you
mustn't do that again
but then
they'd still
encourage me to take big volumes which
they knew i couldn't do without
exporting around the world
so it was this very tenuous relationship
anyway eventually a new manager took
over and he came to see me took me out
to lunch which was a very rare occasion
but we went out to lunch and stoked on
trent and
we talked about the business model and
so on and he said
you know
we don't really like this distribution
model of yours
and
we really
hate the fact that you're undercutting
hate the fact that you're competitive
and it's doing us a lot of damage around
the world
and in the uk
and if anybody was going to do that i'd
be doing it
i
naively at the time took that to mean
motorola wanted to take my distribution
off me
a month later he terminated my
distribution agreement don't forget this
is 90
of my business by then i got 60 or 70
employees huge overheads
and motorola was 90 percent of my
business
he terminated my agreement
and one month later resigned from
motorola
and set up his own distribution business
on the south coast of england
with motorola as his supplier
so he went from general manager to my
competitor by having stripped me
of all of my turnover
how would you deal with that
you tell me
well the way i dealt with it
was
every every challenge in life whether
it's business personal or anything is
just that it's a challenge and there's
always a solution and you've just got to
put your intellect towards what the
solution is
um well so what was the solution here
well i just looked at the marketplace
and there was lots of service providers
who are the people that sold the air
time on behalf of vodafone cellnet and
so on and these service providers were
were distributing motorola of course
because that was 90 of their business
and they were getting discounts
according to the volume they took
so i went and had confident confidential
conversations with a couple of them and
said look why don't i buy from you
and what i can do is i can add my
massive volume onto your volume and
you'll get a huge retrospective discount
a much better buying price we'll have to
keep it secret from motorola because
otherwise they might cut your supply off
but we'll just do it very very
secretively you supply me and i can go
to the market and continue doing what
i'm doing
and i managed to get two suppliers who
bought into that
and supplied me with a kit cheaper than
i'd been buying it before because
motorola had always manipulated me and
given me a price that was far worse than
i should have had for the volume that i
was doing
so i managed to keep going immediately
on that but that wasn't the answer
because i didn't want to help motorola
so another uh another situation occurred
where i asked nokia to come in to see me
they were they were actually quite
reticent to do so um the guy chris jones
who was their sales director eventually
did come and see me we got on like a
house on fire in spite of his reputation
for being a real you know a bit of a
hard nut uh we did just get on very very
well nokia had only got one percent
market share and i said to chris look
we can build this business you'll have
my heart and soul and passion because i
want to kill motorola i want to destroy
them in the same way that they've tried
to destroy me
and we did a deal with one of their
old stock items that they'd failed with
completely and i bought 3000 units which
doesn't sound much now i mean i bought
that every second almost in the later
days of cordwell but uh
at that time it's a monster deal the
biggest ever been done in the
marketplace by anybody and i bought
these 3 000 units at a phenomenally low
price and i was able to put nokia on the
face of the map with these units and
that wouldn't have saved the day for me
had it not been for a bit of a stroke of
luck as well which which was the
nokia decided to get aggressive they
decided that they didn't want to be a
nobody at the mobile phone business
they'd got a new phone coming out the
101 and they really wanted to capture
market share that's music to my ears
because it was a lovely little phone it
was once again before your time really
but but it was a a lot of listeners will
remember especially the older ones
because it was a really famous phone in
its day
and i managed to do a deal with nokia
for huge quantities a phenomenally
advantageous price
and the my goal was to take motorola's
market share off them
to the nth degree not just as a vendetta
but because that was good for my
business and i was really really upset
with motorola because they tried to kill
me you know
and if i hadn't been able to find
solutions i would have i would have been
bankrupt i wouldn't have survived so
we got this nokia 101
and we absolutely blasted it out through
our retail premises through our airtime
retailer services and through just pure
wholesale
and we built nokia up to 20 market share
in a year wow and commensurate at the
same time motorola's market share
started dropping
they were world leader until iphone and
apple came out
so
we helped motor we helped nokia get to
worldly well we could help them to get
to uk leader
and helped motorola's massive decline
and um
listeners might think oh that's you know
a bit
bit harsh but it was not harsh because
you know what what do you do if somebody
wants to destroy you like that in an
unethical way as well you know i don't
mind fair competition but it was very
unethical they'd help me build up to
what i was i had helped build their
market share then it didn't suit them
but it was mostly on an unethical
general manager who just wanted to kill
my distribution and re remove my
distributorship so he could set up on
his own
on that day where you get that
email whatever it was i don't know i
didn't
really know how people were
communicating back then because i wasn't
alive but you get that message that um
motorola are terminating your contract
what is the
and you've got 70 employees you've got
this great business that's growing
quickly and it's probably you know
really taking you out of
um
it's giving you a new life potentially
right and you get that message that they
are terminating your contract on the day
when you read the message how does it
feel emotionally
take me through the range
utter despair
utter despair
um
on the one hand
and
fires up the lion in me on the other
and i have got a lion in me you know and
uh
my brother once wrote a poem about that
that i could be the kindest and best
friend but don't make me an enemy
i i but but just for clarity for your
list i don't i don't hold grudges
against anybody ever you know but if
somebody really really goes at me
um they'd better beware
and so it was a combination of these two
aspects sleepless nights nights oh
absolutely i don't have sleepless nights
but i did on that because
it was terminal if i didn't find a
solution it was instantly terminal you
know my turnover was going to drop
immediately my stores were empty
nothing
no future
and all those employees would have been
able to work i'd have been bankrupt and
i wouldn't be here talking to you today
i had to find a solution
and i did it with with ferocity
and passion
drive you know and i would not sweep a
moment until i found
enough solutions not just one solution
enough solutions that gave me insulation
and what i always say to people going
into business
follow my 10 rule about everything
never have more than 10 percent of your
supplies with any one supplier
never have 10 of your sales with any one
customer and never have 10 of the
responsibility with any one employee now
we can't all achieve that i certainly
couldn't achieve it and i've never been
able to achieve it since but it's a goal
to have in mind because that insulates
you from any catastrophe whatsoever
so you know if if people in business
have got any business that was similar
to mine where you're relying on
customers and suppliers and so on the 10
rule
um that i
sort of innovated as a consequence of my
uh experiences is an absolute golden
rule to try and emulate
i love that and the reason i i really
dwell on the point of like having those
moments of like existential terminal
risk is because on
i feel pretty much all entrepreneurs
especially if they they go on for long
enough we'll encounter a moment like
that and i did in my life many of them
and in hindsight you realize how your
response in those moments ends up being
really really defining and also i view
those moments as inevitable regardless
of what you do and thirdly
the risk is that entrepreneurs will
think
those moments are a
are evidence of their own inadequacy
and that this is a sign that they should
give up whereas you know having read
through your story you go through
moments of kind of like existential risk
and crisis over and over again
um and you know it was just the nature
of the business yeah you know it was
it was a horrible business it really was
a horrible business i mean i'm
it's created all my wealth yeah and
i'm very grateful to the business but it
was a horrible business that was
i was sitting on the edge of my seat
nearly every day for 20 years facing
threat after threat after threat after
threat there was never a day went by
there i didn't
face a fairly significant threat
um
not of the significance that i've just
talked about but there were just endless
threats
and you know it was really
really actually very tiring and not
enjoyable at all a lot of people that i
know have said oh this is so enjoyable
well not for me it wasn't i mean i
enjoyed the success and i enjoyed some
moments and some victories
but it was almost like um
i can't imagine really how a heroine had
it feels but uh i think i think i was a
heroin addict you know i'd get my shot
of heroin
and everything would be wonderful for an
hour or two and then the rest of it was
despair isn't that so bizarre that you
would choose that you would choose the
pain and chaos versus just you could
have gone and done something else john
you could have gone and just worked a
nice nine-to-five job and been
comfortable why are you choosing
struggle and pain
just
in my dna you know i i visualized when i
was seven or eight years old
um and it was an immensely strong vision
visualization
of
being in a chauffeur driven rolls royce
and a show for driven rolls-royce
because my father
admired them and said they were the best
koi in the world and only rich people
had them blah blah blah
so i'm in a chauffeur driven rolls royce
driving around the streets of shelton
which is the back streets of stokentran
and handing five-pound pound notes out
to poor people
that became
i don't know why but it became my
destiny
that that destiny sat over me like a
damocles sword you know you've got to
achieve that destiny else you've just
failed completely in life you have to do
it you have to do the wealth and then
you have to give that wealth away to
make people's lives better
so i didn't have any choice
i know it sounds bizarre but i had no
choice it's like now
a lot of my life is stressful on the
charity work but i don't have any choice
you know i give up and sacrifice lots of
personal things to do the things that
i'm doing from a charitable perspective
i mean don't get me wrong i have a great
lifestyle i don't want any sympathy on
that but i'm just saying i do and it's
my destiny and i can't give it up you
know people say well why did you do this
why did you why'd you miss out on things
that you could be doing why don't you
just take it easy why don't you earn
that i said well i've got no choice it's
just written into my dna i must do it
and uh
and so i do you know it's just who i am
i can't explain it really it's just who
i am
being dragged by that sense of
mission towards that north star of the
rolls royce giving out the five pound
notes or even now with all the
charitable work you do
you describe it as not being a choice
which kind of means that it's just like
you're being pulled in that direction
the cost again which i always like to
shine a light on as well as you've
described as you you said at the time
you didn't have any friends
throughout that period and you described
you know those 20 years as 20 years of
grief talk to me about the loneliness
point
i heard you say i think it was on desert
island discs your interview there that
you didn't have friends
no but i wasn't lonely i mean i had a
wonderful wife
um eventually went on to have uh
two children during that time or three
eventually
um
and i wasn't lonely at all um
i lived for the business and i'd got
some great relationships within the
business with people who
you know i was really close to craig
benny who was my finance director as
they want but monitored i felt with him
i felt like he was my brother but my
brother was in the business as well
so there were these close relationships
within the business not very many but
enough to to not feel lonely and then i
got my wife and children at home
so the loneliness never
never came to fruition i wouldn't ever
want to go back to that because i've now
got a huge number of friends and uh some
very special friends
and
and a lot of loving relationships
so i would never want to give that up
but actually the charity is part of that
because some of the children that we've
helped in cordwell children
are immensely successful in their own
right i was telling somebody only
yesterday that one of the children we
helped when she was three years old was
tilly
until he has type 2 muscular atrophy
which stops all the muscles working
she actually won
of her own
absolute brilliance and effort a
scholarship at stanford university
i mean it's unbelievable
now
i'm not responsible for that i helped
because we supplied her with a
wheelchair that she could not have
probably succeeded without it but her
and her parents and other support groups
around her we all as a team but her
mainly more than anybody
made this happen
and i visited her at stanford university
we went for a coffee together and uh
she's in a wheelchair the one that we
supplied you know with a little joystick
buzzing along the pavement i'm there on
my bike i'd cycle down from her son's
house and they're cycling along she's
in a wheelchair we get to starbucks i go
and buy her coffee
and she's got this starbucks coffee on a
tray in front of her wheelchair
and she's got a support mechanism on her
arm
that gives her gives a little bit extra
stiffness
and this coffee's quite a big coffee and
she lifts it up but i'm thinking
i didn't really know understand how she
was doing that which clearly didn't
understand his wheelchair worked and i
said
tilly i thought your arm was too weak to
lift a weight like that she said it is
i said well how are you doing that she
said oh i've got two foot pedals there
and one of them well the foot pedals
motorize right this this this bracket
that lifts her arm so she got power
assisted on
and she's drinking this coffee and i'm
thinking the the absolute trauma that
she's gone through in life and yet she's
done everything with grace with spirit
with enthusiasm even ending up at
stanford university
you know six thousand five thousand
miles from home
i mean it's amazing
and
joint like that
can never be replaced by anything i can
have all the boats in the world all the
helicopters all the trappings that i do
have which are lovely and wonderful
but without that they wouldn't mean much
to me and it's that sense of spiritual
satisfaction
from changing a person's life especially
a child's that you'll never get from
restaurant meals or boats or holidays
you just never get it yeah you enjoy it
and i take all my friends and i have a
lovely time really enjoy it but does it
really
go down into my heart
like
the 60 000 children we've helped and the
tillies of this world no can't even
begin to compete
quick one this is maybe a good segue to
talk about a little bit of an
announcement i have to make which is we
have a brand new sponsor for the podcast
and some of you if you've seen my social
media posts will know that i often wear
a lot of jewelry and the brand that i'm
wearing is a brand called crafted as you
can see on the table in front of me if
you're watching this on youtube crafted
are brands that sell really meaningful
affordable men's jewelry so i reached
out to the founders of crafted alex and
danny and asked them if they wanted to
sponsor the podcast and they said they
did they listen to the podcast they like
what we do here the podcast is a place
of meaning and their journey is all
about meaning and so we forged a new
partnership the piece of jewelry i wear
the most i want to introduce you to the
pieces and why i wear them is this sand
timer unsurprisingly and the thing for
me about sand timer is it's probably the
most clear reminder that our time here
on earth is finite so as the episodes go
on i'll introduce a piece of jewelry and
i'll tell you the meaning it has for me
and why i wear it
we get to the end of your story at
phones for you and um
and you've you've had this tremendous
you know exit which makes you a
billionaire
what was there a pivotal moment where
you did the penny drop for you that you
would your next sort of source of
meaning would be setting up coldwell
children and doing so much sort of
philanthropy and the pledge you made to
the melinda gates foundation to give
away your your worth and the initiatives
you've launched with the great british
entrepreneur was to support young people
into into their
their career paths was there a pivotal
moment where you decided that
this was now your new meaning there was
absolutely i mean everything that you've
described there was evolutionary but
there was an absolute pivotal point
because
during the the years of growing the
business and i've already tried to
describe the difficulties and challenges
i faced in that i was all consumed
and charity was the last thing on my
mind
but the destiny was still written in
stone somewhere in my dna it was just
buried by the
need to
maintain the success and keep the
success and not lose it and there were
so many threats that i had to be a 100
focus
one day the uh
uh
the nspcc came to me and said there's a
lord taverner's cricket i don't know why
i held this meeting but i did it was a
charity meeting and they said there's a
lord taverner's cricket match in stone
would you sponsor it
and they gave me the details and i
thought
well
it's not going to raise a lot of money
and
and somehow i evolved in that uh meeting
to taking over it and being largely
responsible for running it and making it
successful and it was celebrities that
were playing cricket against um other
celebrities you know and uh just a
fundraiser that was in the local cricket
room it didn't make a massive sum of
money but that was
the moment that that really got me
involved
but then the nspcc realizing i could be
a useful asset
got me and
got me to come down to a centre and have
a uh have a uh
an understanding of the work they did
which i didn't really understand
i knew it was to help children but i
didn't really understand
and when they showed me videos and
talked me through
it was young children sometimes as young
as three and four or five sexually
abused
often by a relative maybe the father
maybe the mother or an uncle or a friend
and they were sexually abused
and i'm looking at this in horror
but what was even more horrible if
anything could be
was that the child then couldn't do
anything about it because daddy would
say you don't want daddy to get in
trouble do you for showing his love
um daddy will go to jail and you don't
want that do you
so this
sexual abuse would just continue and
continue and continue
and the older the child would get the
more the child would think
this is horrible horrible and feel
guilty and dreadful about it
but the same threat that the father
would go to jail was sitting over them
i thought just how horrendous is that
how horrendous so i got really bought
into the nspcc then i immediately fired
into action
um ended up
as president of the north staffs branch
for a short period of time
what happened next was i mean that was
the pivotal moment really but what
happened next was
the nspcc is a fantastic charity but i
wasn't getting enough satisfaction out
of hands-on seen the difference i'd made
and i knew i could do a lot more
and so i decided to found my own charity
which was called all children
and with the objective of helping every
child in the uk that needed help
and the only qualifier wouldn't be
anything to do with what illness or what
the only qualifier is that the parents
couldn't get the help anywhere else
so any child with any illness
serious illness
we would be there to help and that's
what we've done and up to yet help 60
000 and still growing it enormously now
and to avoid the criticisms the nspcc
had which was that the overheads were
high and i'm not criticizing that
because i'd have to really understand
the nuts and bolts of everything um so
i'm certainly not
implying any criticism of that but they
were criticized for the overheads being
too high like a lot of charities are i
decided that uh the cordwell group would
pay every single running cost of the
charity so all the wages all the cars
all the telephones everything and not
only that but every single employee
would be involved in the charity in some
way either by donating themselves or by
fundraising to try and uh raise money
for these kids
that's what we did it's it's just deeply
tremendously inspiring and um
as i read through your story there's a
bit of a almost a cruel irony to the
fact that then your own child was in
need of the services that you were and
the support that you were giving to so
many other children
your son rufus got sick with lyme
disease yeah yeah it was a huge irony
really because all of my kids were very
very healthy and i felt hugely
privileged and even more privileged when
i got involved at the nspcc and saw
these tragic cases of abuse
and then when i set up cordwell
children's for all these children that
so desperately needed help and who'd
been born with nothing you know
in a traumatic situation
and uh i felt unbelievably lucky and
that look lasted for i suppose
six years
i think rufus fell ill
no seven or eight years and then rufus
fell ill with lyme disease and
panspandus
and uh we didn't know any of this at the
time because none of the doctors knew
anything about it
uh he just fell in with anxiety
i think with anxiety he collapsed on me
i was taking him back to school on a
sunday night he was at boarding school
which was all my children that went to
boarding school but as their request was
never something i wanted them to do
particularly but they wanted to do it so
rufus went to boarding school he was
home for an exia and on the sunday night
he said dad i don't want to go to school
well i'd had that with all my children
because as much as they wanted to go to
boarding school
after the weekend at home with the
family
you know they'd feel emotional about it
and wouldn't really want to leave the
family home
and i knew i had to be quite hard and
firm and cold about it you know and say
no of course you do rufus you know it's
always like this you get this
pain in the pit of your stomach that
you're leaving the family home and
you're going to school but it's fine you
know you'll be fine once we get in the
car we just go
i said no dad this is different
and i said what do you mean so don't be
silly
and i tried everything in my power to be
persuasive inspirational
hard
i tried every emotion to get him in that
car
almost to the point of physically
dragging him not that i did but i was
feeling like come on rufus please get in
the car you know you you know you'll be
fine once we get on the road because i
had it with my other children i knew
exactly what was going on or so i
thought
anyway i never did that didn't get him
to school
and i actually never got him to school
again
not properly
and the next day he's still in a
dreadful state it wasn't really anxiety
it's just they couldn't leave the home
well it must have been anxiety but i
couldn't explain it
and
we took him to a therapist the therapist
started doing all the you know the retro
retrograde looking at his life and blah
blah blah blah was there any traumatic
events and there wasn't and just going
through everything
nobody over the next few years could
find anything that was causing this
illness nothing
and eventually
and this was only about seven or eight
years ago after he'd been suffering
already for about
uh uh probably the best part of bay nine
years already
um we found out that it got lyme disease
and we didn't know about panzer
pandestan now lyme disease can show as a
set of physical and neuro conditions but
also neurological it can attack the
brain and cause neurological situations
where your brain is unable to respond
appropriately and normally because of
this bacterial infection
um we treated him for that but he didn't
he never really
he just deteriorated carried on
deteriorating
to the point where
he was utterly suicidal
he'd lie on the bed rocking
all day pulling his hair out screaming
screaming he just wanted to die and he's
since told us that the only reason he
didn't kill himself was because we were
there fighting every second of the day
to keep him alive and fighting with the
authorities and the medical people to
try and find a solution and he was like
my mother really surrounded by love and
if you surround somebody by love it
makes it more difficult for them to
to do something not that would stop
everybody but you know he rufus
said that's what kept him alive and we
kept him alive we had to have 24
supervision in the bedroom
in case he jumped out the window
um i don't know whether he ever would
have done that but that's the way it was
and it was a very traumatic period of my
life for many many years i'm lucky
because my ex-wife was utterly devoted
to him and looked after him and when she
was then no longer able to my eldest
daughter took on the mantle and became
an amazing amazing carer for him and
just
looked after him to the to her own
self-sacrifice massive self-sacrifice
actually because she lived rufus's life
even though she got a husband and a life
in america she just lived rufus life
with him
so we had a lot of amazing support and
then we found out about panz pandas
and nobody knows about panzpander so
it's one of my great big campaigns over
the next few years
to not to to make sure all the medical
authorities understand transpanders
understand that it's a real illness
understand the symptoms and and start
working out what the very best treatment
is
anyway we found some experts and they've
been treating pants pandas for a few
years so we we took rufus over
and uh jenny frankovic this expert on uh
panzpander started treating him
anyway he still didn't really get a lot
better he had ups and downs
but it got these horrible horrible
symptoms that transpanders people get
they get a whole range of symptoms and
uh i hope your listeners will go on to
the panzer pandas the website and look
at these symptoms because some of your
listeners will have a young child who
are suffering from transpanders and they
won't be getting the help that they need
or the diagnosis so i really hope they
go on and look at this because it might
transform their lives and the lives of
their child but this is a big challenge
i've got going forward to get this out
there this message out there and it's
quite easily identifiable at first
because it's the same thing it's a
collapse
of somebody that's fairly sudden
unexpected and for not really any
identifiable reason
and there's a whole range of symptoms
but some of those are absolutely anxiety
fear now in rufus case he went on to
develop all sorts of symptoms like air
hunger which is horrendous and air
hunger is best described i mean i can't
describe it really very well because
i've never don't i don't really
understand it but rufus has described it
as like somebody puts a plastic bag over
your head and seals it and you're
gasping like this for every last breath
until it passes and that's one of the uh
symptoms and the things that happen as
one of these anxieties agoraphobia
hemetophobia a whole range of uh of
symptoms and lots of others as well
anyway eventually we ended up moving
rufus down to um from stanford down to
l.a where we'd found a whole psychiatric
team we wanted to put him in a clinic
first of all but now bernie manny
couldn't travel every time we moved him
even
even five miles from the house was
traumatic traumatic for him and
traumatic for us anyway we did manage to
get him to i actually bought a two
hundred thousand pounds american motor
home
put wi-fi in it to try and make the
journey tolerable to him in concept and
in reality
uh but it was still traumatic taking him
down in this one winnebago and anyway we
got him under this team of people i'm
not going to tell the story from there
on because it was it's a bit long and
also
there's a lot more trauma to come but
he's now
in really great shape he's not cured but
he's living a good life and a happy life
and can liaise and relate to everything
and and he's inspiring other people so
it's uh
it's
i hope
that the trauma that we've been through
that he's been through more importantly
we can turn to making him the biggest
ambassador for panz pandas
and for using his
dreadful situation to help
hundreds of thousands of other children
around the world to avoid it or
understand it and deal with it better
it's wonderfully um inspiring and it's
it's also
really incredible to hear that he's he's
living a life where he has found
happiness and he's been able to
to create a life despite not being fully
cured that is um
you know has meaning to it so
and we hope we are hoping for a full
cure you know we're hoping that he'll be
able to travel
one day soon
but for the moment he can just go down
we got in this house especially right on
the side of beverly hills i mean also
wealth comes into this you know we're so
lucky to have the wealth because when
you get a child like that
like our children with cordwell children
you haven't got the resources to help
them it's devastating you've got the
most devastating situation with your
child
but you're unable to do anything
financially to do what you need to do
anyway yeah we bought him this house on
the side of hollywood hills
and he's only five minutes away from um
sunset boulevard
so he's got a life commuting between the
two
girlfriend
and a lovely life you know and all we
need to do now is get him to the next
level where he can travel and maybe um
find a meaningful
um
form of employment to give him proper
satisfaction that might just be
spreading the word of panz pandas and i
pay him a wage to do that you know but
whatever it is
i i think he's definitely on the pathway
to a fulfilling life
and and that's
thanks to my daughter my ex-wife and all
the effort my family have put in
alongside jenny frankovich and in
stamford and the psychiatrists in uh in
la so it's quite a happy result and uh
and i think that there's
you know there's an old expression where
there's life there's hope and there is
really hope for those plans pandas kids
but we need to get the message out
when i hear that story and i reflect on
another experience which we haven't
talked about which was you getting
almost critically injured on your bike
last year when you were cycling and you
broke i don't know was it 12 12 bones
and
i mean that was a near-death experience
for you
the loss of your mother
recently
what have you learned about through
these moments of grief and you know
new death experiences of your own and
you know the situation with rufus what
have you learned about what what
actually matters in life
well i i i think i always really knew i
just wasn't very good at implementing it
and that's
[Music]
just
i think loving people caring for society
and making the world a better place and
i think if you can do that
no matter who you are no matter how
little money you've got if you can just
contribute to society in a positive way
the feelings are immensely positive
um but there's the obvious lessons that
health is critical i mean i did nearly
die on that
mountain road in italy i could have had
a death from four or five different
reasons because the injuries were so
severe
um and health is
utterly utterly vital
but uh but that's an obvious statement
but i think when you've experienced as
much ill health as i have
mainly with my family
but also
these accidents i've had which have been
an endless stream of accidents over the
last 40 years which yourself impose you
know it's entirely my own fault it's the
way i live my life i live my life for
thrills you know as well as making the
world a better place i have my own world
which is you know fairly adventurous and
risky and the last thing i wanted to ask
you about is i guess it's a bit of
advice i guess because
i in running my businesses over the
years and being a very driven ambitious
man have um sacrificed um and not been
very good historically at sustaining
romantic relationships you've had you
know you reference your former partner
there with such admiration and you have
you know an amicable relationship with
her but over the years what lessons have
you learned about how to strive
and be driven whilst also trying to
maintain
um a romantic relationship and also i'd
say the sub question to that is are
romantic relationships important
i am male yeah yeah
i think the first thing is that i
wouldn't change anything uh on that and
i was utterly focused
on business
to the detriment of my wife and family
but
i say detriment self critically because
i'm not sure it's i'm not really sure
that's true because
i know i was always as kind as possible
always as loving as possible and always
would put
important events forward so my children
would probably say if they
said did you get enough of dad and
they'd say well we didn't get that much
of him but when he mattered when it
mattered to us he was there
when we'd got a problem he was there and
i would always if there was a
significant problem like that employer
told you about it was broken down up
when there was a when somebody really
needs me
i'm absolutely there for anybody
important in my life but i wasn't able
to be a devoted doting person but it's
who i am and i don't you know i probably
wouldn't change it but
so this work-life balance i don't
believe it look if you want to run a
business make sure that your wife's on
board make sure that she understands the
potential sacrifices and make sure you
do and make sure you've got the six
critical success factors
and if all of those are ticks in the box
go for it if there's a lack of ticks in
the box be cautious because there's more
people damaged by going into business
then there is those people that are
pleased that they're dead it's not this
romantic notion oh i'll run my own list
and we'll be wealthy we'll have a lovely
house and a beautiful car it's not like
that at all it's hardship and graft for
most people
make sure you want it make sure your
wife and family want it
and then if all those boxes it takes
yeah fantastic go full steam ahead and
give everything you've got make it a
success
but just don't get yourself into a huge
mess that you never really
thought that could happen to you
well that's a perfect note to end on and
that's really why i started this podcast
at the end of the day is to shine that
much more realistic light on the pursuit
of business and being a ceo i want to
thank you for for not just the
inspiration but really also you know as
i got to really dig into the
philanthropic work that you're doing now
it really inspired me and as someone
that has managed to have some relative
success in my life it got me thinking
about the fact that i need to be doing
more and your pledge to you know you
were one of the first britons to pledge
to the linda gates foundation that you'd
be giving away 70 of your wealth in your
life which again inspired me really
really tremendously as a young
entrepreneur and to hear that you found
such meaning in this philanthropic
charitable work now in the same way that
you did in your business venture again
is tremendously inspiring to me as a
young businessman we have a closing
tradition on the podcast which is the
previous guest asks the next guest a
question
um and i okay
i read it now so this is the first time
i read it when you are older and looking
back on the next chapter of your life
what would it need to include for you to
look back and smile
well firstly i am older
but when i'm older still it's more of
the same i need to love and respect all
those people around me
i need to change a lot more people's
lives than i'm already doing a heck of a
lot more over the next 10 years if i'm
lucky enough to live that
and
and drive everything forward for the
benefit of people but also make a
success of my businesses so all of that
i'm quite greedy you see
but also probably to get stephen
bartlett to come to my next charity ball
and take a table and be supportive of
all these children that we help and
bring in some of your amazing clientele
and connections that's a promise okay
thank you so much john appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you